يمكنك سماع الخوف من الصراخ
هناك وفقًا لمسؤولي وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الإيرانية
يصفون الانفجارات
ويطلقون على هذه الانفجارات
هجومًا إرهابيًا على الجهاز العصبي المركزي ندى بشير يتابع هذا
من أجلنا ندى ما هو
الأحدث جيدًا هذه بالتأكيد
قصة متطورة جون ما زلنا
الحصول على مزيد من التفاصيل من المسؤولين ووسائل
الإعلام على الأرض في إيران، ولكن في
الساعة الماضية أو نحو ذلك رأينا أن
عدد القتلى يرتفع بشكل مطرد، حيث قُتل ما لا يقل عن 103
أشخاص وأصيب 141 آخرين وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام الرسمية في إيران نقلاً عن مسؤولين على
الأرض، وبعض المصابين
يقال إنهم في حالة حرجة، وقد
رأينا تلك اللقطات الدرامية التي
ظهرت من مكان الحادث والتي تظهر حشودًا
تهرب من موقع الانفجار،
ورأينا سيارات الإسعاف وخدمات الطوارئ
تتجمع وهم ينقلون الناس إلى
المستشفيات القريبة الآن بالطبع ما
زلنا نحصل على  مزيد من التفاصيل حول
تفاصيل هذين الانفجارين
وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية مرة أخرى نقلاً عن
مسؤولين على الأرض، وقع الانفجار الأول على
بعد حوالي 700 متر من
مدافن القائد الإيراني الراحل
كوم سواني، ووقع الانفجار الثاني على
بعد حوالي كيلومتر واحد من مدافن القائد الإيراني الراحل كوم سواني.  من
المهم الآن ملاحظة نقاط التفتيش والمسار الذي كان يمر فيه الزوار لزيارة موقع الدفن، حيث كان من
الممكن أن تكون هناك حشود ضخمة
وقت وقوع هذا الانفجار، ويصادف اليوم مرور 4 سنوات
على مقتل القائد قاسم السوماني
في غارة أمريكية على مطار بغداد
الدولي.  المطار أمر به الرئيس الأمريكي آنذاك
دونالد ترامب لذلك كنا
نتوقع رؤية حشود ضخمة
هناك وبالطبع يأتي هذا في وقت
تتصاعد فيه التوترات في المنطقة وما
زلنا ننتظر الحصول على مزيد من التفاصيل
حول تفاصيل الدافع
ربما  وراء الهجوم الذي ربما يكون هو من
نفذ الهجوم،
وصفت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الإيرانية مرة أخرى
هذا الهجوم بأنه هجوم إرهابي،
ولكن مرة أخرى هناك توترات تتصاعد في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة خاصة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالجماعات المتحالفة
مع إيران أو المدعومة منها والتي هي بالتأكيد  أما بالنسبة
للقضية هنا في لبنان، فإننا
نتوقع اليوم أن نسمع من الأمين
العام لمجموعة الحسبة الخلفية الإيرانية
الجنرال حسن نصاح، ومن المتوقع أن
يتحدث بعد حوالي ساعة أو نحو ذلك، لذلك
سننتظر لنرى ما
سيقوله حول القضية هنا في لبنان.  الوضع في إيران،
وبالطبع إحياء ذكرى وفاة كوم
سواني، من المهم أن نلاحظ بالطبع أن
هذا يأتي بعد يوم واحد فقط من رأينا
هجومًا آخر هنا في المبنى الذي خلفي،
وهو قائد كبير في حماس، صلاح الوري،
قُتل في غارة مساء الثلاثاء
وفقًا لـ  مسؤول أمريكي أن الضربة
نفذتها إسرائيل، حماس
تشير بالتأكيد بأصابع الاتهام بشكل مباشر
إلى إسرائيل، لكن في هذه المرحلة،
لم يعلن المسؤولون الإسرائيليون
مسؤوليتهم
عن تلك الضربة ولم ينفوا مسؤوليتهم عنها.